okay
thank you
three minutes
now is it when they walk out the doors
when they start speaking
when they get i would say a good split
is when they get to the rake
they don't actually have to start
speaking
we went to break
okay here we go
[Music]
all right good morning everybody i'm
joined here by mayor nancy rotaring and
chief of police lou jogman my name is
chris covelli c-o-v-e-l-l-i and i'm the
spokesman for the lake county major
crime task force uh this morning we're
going to provide you with some updates
about where the investigation has led
thus far where we're at and where we're
going to be moving forward
so over the past 24 hours there's been a
significant
amount of information obtained by
investigators and this consists of the
extremely hard work by highland park
police the major crime task force state
police atf and the fbi
everybody has been collaborating very
well to further this investigation the
community has been absolutely terrific
as it comes to reporting
information that they have things they
may have witnessed things they may have
seen turning over video that has really
helped us
further the investigation and aid
investigators one point i just want to
clarify is robert cremo the third he's
21 he'll be 22 in september of this year
and he's a resident of highwood
so throughout the past 24 hours
investigators have spoken with numerous
witnesses
some of the survivors they've had the
opportunity to review numerous video
clips both from cell phone video
recordings and fixed cameras in the area
and they've con conducted a number of
other follow-up investigations and based
on where we're at at this point in the
investigation and some of this is still
preliminary so is subject to change as
we keep moving forward but we do believe
cremo pre-planned this attack for
several weeks
uh he brought a high-powered rifle to
this parade
he accessed the roof of a business via a
fire escape ladder
and began opening fire on the innocent
independence day celebration goers
the rifle was purchased in illinois and
the information we have thus far is that
it appears to have been purchased
legally by cremo
during the attack primo was dressed in
woman's clothing and investigators do
believe he did this to conceal his
facial tattoos and his identity and help
him during the escape with the other
people who were fleeing the chaos
during the attack we believe that karimo
fired more than 70 rounds from this
rifle into the crowd of innocent people
following the attack cremo exited the
roof he dropped his rifle and he blended
in with the crowd and he escaped uh he
walked to his mother's home who lived in
the area and he blended right in with
everybody else as they were running
around almost as he was
an innocent spectator as well
he borrowed his mother's vehicle
we issued an alert yesterday afternoon
chief jogman provided the vehicle
information and primo's information
we're very thankful that an alert member
of the community saw primo's vehicle
traveling southbound on route 41
dialed 9-1-1
an alert north chicago police officer
spotted the vehicle waited for
additional backup units to arrive
conducted a traffic stop and they were
able to safely apprehend primo with no
injuries to the officers
inside the vehicle there was a second
rifle located
indications is that was purchased by
cremo as well
thus far over 30 people were injured
during the attack and this does not
include the six who lost their lives
right now cremo remains in custody at
this time
uh there are no indications that there
was anybody else involved in this attack
by all indications it appears primo was
acting by himself the lake county
state's attorney's office has been with
us from the ground level they're with us
this morning they were with us through
the night we continue to review the
information investigators are still
developing
leads and very critical information once
we're at a point where we're ready to
review all of that information for
charges we will sit down with the
state's attorney and review for criminal
charges
i'm going to turn this over to the mayor
and then i'll be back up to answer
questions
mayor thank you thank you
today is a day of grieving together
a day to pause a day to remember those
who left us
those who were injured and for strength
for our community
several vigil and prayer services are
taking place today both inside and
beyond highland park they are as follows
the community church of lake bluff
117 east scranton avenue lake bluff will
hold a prayer service today
at noon
the service will include prayer and
music at christ church on the corner of
route 60 and waukegan avenue in lake
forest
trinity grace church and christ church
has organized a community prayer
gathering at 3 p.m at trinity grace
church 1506
half day road highland park everyone is
welcome
highland park presbyterian church
trinity episcopal and other area faith
leaders will hold an economic
accumulable
ecumenical community prayer vigil today
at 7 pm at the highland park
presbyterian church 330 laurel avenue
highland park all are welcome today
highland park high school located at 433
vine avenue in conjunction with
community partners is host hosting
crisis counseling until 2 pm and is open
to everyone
no appointments are necessary
additionally a family assistance center
will open tomorrow july 6 at noon to
provide support services and crisis
assistance to those who were directly
impacted at the parade the location and
hours of operations are pending we'll
get that information to the community as
soon as we have it
please go to the city website for more
information
the highland park police department the
american red cross and the fbi victim
services response team are assisting
with additional partners the teams will
engage with victims and families to
assess their immediate needs and provide
crisis intervention and other forms of
emergency assistance
anyone who is a victim of the incident
and is in need of support can call
call fbi
i know what a generous community we are
a part of
we are overwhelmed with the amount of
support offered not only from those in
highland park but the surrounding region
and throughout the nation
thank you
for those who are looking to donate to
victims and in support of the community
we ask that you be mindful of potential
scams on gofundme and other fundraising
avenues this afternoon we'll share
additional information on the city's
website regarding how to donate to the
victims survivors and those who support
the community for all who have reached
out with offers of equipment food and
professional services we thank you
thank you all for coming out today i'll
now turn the mic back to deputy chief
covelli
any questions
at this point we have not developed a
motive from him uh investigators are
very much furthering the investigation
they have been in discussions with him
i don't have anything to say about
motivation thus far because it hasn't
been provided
the question was there's disturbing
videos online that have been seen
we are reviewing those those are going
to be a part of any investigation
efforts by our task force investigators
highland park police we'll look at them
and we'll see what they reveal
the question was
where did he purchase the weapons and
did he tell his mother uh what he had
done
he purchased the weapons locally within
the region so the chicagoland area
uh when he went to his mother's we have
no indication that he provided any
information to her
so he was in possession of the firearm
the day of the rifle he was in
possession of another rifle in his
vehicle when he was pulled over by
police um
he also had other firearms that were
recovered from a residence that he was
living in in woods were all in his name
they were in his name
they were legally purchased
right so how did you guys identify him
at this point i mean there was a lot of
planning do you have an idea when he
placed himself on the
roof so so we are working on the
timeline and we don't want to come out
with any accurate information on timing
um
one of the asks that we have is members
of the community if you have any video
of this individual
that is walking toward the parade at the
parade uh potentially on the roof or
exiting to please call 1-800 call fbi as
far as the disguise went um
he wore that an attempt to conceal
himself
i can't get into that right now there
have been some law enforcement contacts
nothing of a violent nature i can't get
into the specifics of the context of
that and how many rifles our colleagues
at nbc's are reporting that you purchase
multiple weapons can you give us any
details of the
at this time i know of the two rifles
and i know that there were potentially
pistols that he he had owned as well
uh i'm not going to go into what he may
or may not have said the investigation
is still moving forward i'll provide
that information later on
shooting appears to be completely random
is it possible that he chose the
community because of the high population
of jewish people i know people are
concerned that it was an anti-semitic
attack we have no information to suggest
at this point it was racially motivated
motivated by religion or any other
protected status of all the videos of
all the videos that appeared
i believe still in place is an assault
rifle ban in highland park is that
correct yeah i don't have information on
that right now but we will get back to
you on specifically all the videos of
primo prior to this did anyone ever call
highland park police or tip off
authorities that these were online no we
were not we were not made aware of these
videos
so investigators did a really good job
the atf was phenomenal yesterday they
expedited a trace of the firearm that
was a major investigative lead for us in
addition to that the witness statements
the videos that we obtained from
people that turned them in and the
businesses they all helped us
tremendously
the information i have right now is that
all of those that were either
transported to the hospital or
self-drove themselves to the hospital
were injured by gunfire so
over 30 individuals that were injured by
the gunfire and they went to the three
hospitals we mentioned yesterday
as a woman how were you able to identify
so early on that you were looking for
for a male and the atrium
he was identified by a a number of uh
there were police officers that were
able to recognize his photo once it was
revealed and that helped us
so it was a high-powered rifle that was
used it was uh
shot high-velocity rounds
it could be similar to an ar-15 it was
similar to an ar-15 as far as
identifying him with the woman's he was
seen on on video camera in the woman's
clothes video camera
played a tremendous role and how we were
able to identify him both
leaving initially and as he left chris
different and bought at separate
locations did he also have any more to a
disguise did he have a wig on because it
was recorded
i'm not exactly sure what the woman's
attire consisted of initially it was
reported that this person had long hair
so a wig isn't out of the question
can you repeat that
it was a local business right in that
vicinity i'm not sure the name of the
business uh he was able to access the
roof through a ladder that's affixed to
the side of the building we'll take
three
clothing did he more
it somewhere or did he have it on here
sure
one of the things that that is important
to remember here is
the diligence and investigation we're
gonna reach out to everybody we possibly
can that has information first-hand
information about him whether that's
family members teachers
friends whoever it is that has
information but it does take time it
takes time to gather who may know him
who knew him in the past teachers that
is something that task force
investigators are working on they've
interviewed a number of people thus far
but please keep in mind we're 24 hours
in there's a lot of work to be done here
we're not done
i don't want to get into levels of
cooperation
no indication the weapons were modified
one more one more
children have passed away we'll take
your last one
i'm not sure what address he gave i can
get back to you on that all right we'll
be back this afternoon about three
o'clock we hopefully have an updated
status on charges he'll remain in
custody at this point
thank you everybody
sorry telemundo
sorry
be closed just because of everything
going in we're working on getting you
guys some sort of bathroom